as we begin in Israel where there is
still anger against planned judicial
changes despite the Prime Minister
halting the controversial overhaul some
people are demanding Benjamin
netanyahu's resignation more unrest is
expected a day after large
demonstrations and Nationwide strikes
Netanyahu says delaying the judicial
overhaul will allow for discussions with
the opposition to avoid what he called a
civil war
from a national responsibility from the
will to avoid the rift within the people
I decided to suspend the second and
third reading from the law in this
knesset tenure in order to give time to
get to a broad consensus to pass the
Legislation during the next knesset
meanwhile political groups that oppose
the Prime Minister and his far-right
coalition government is setting up
negotiating teams in an effort to end
the crisis
we've had a bad experience in the past
so first we'll make sure there are no
tricks or bluffing here we heard with
concern yesterday reports that Netanyahu
told people close to him that he isn't
really stopping just trying to calm the
situation live now to Al jazeera's
Natasha go name in West Jerusalem Forest
so Natasha the protests continued even
after Netanyahu announced a pause in the
judicial overhaul bring us up to speed
with the latest and what are people
asking for now
foreign
overhaul may have been paused but it
appears that people and their positions
are entrenched as ever there is still a
great deal of anger across the country
the opposition says in the coming days
it will continue to protest they say
that it's not enough to hit the pause
button on this judicial overhaul they
want it scrapped completely many are
calling for the removal of prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu they're
asking him more specifically to resign
something that would be very unlikely
and supporters of the judicial overhaul
are also extremely dissatisfied and are
planning protests one is planned in Tel
Aviv on Thursday they say this country
needs judicial overhaul that they are
the majority and they won't allow anyone
to steal quote their Vote or the state
from them in an attempt to try to defuse
this political crisis Netanyahu address
us the nation on Monday night he said if
there's an opportunity to avoid a Civil
War through dialogue he is going to take
it he is calling for dialogue with all
parties he says that there's a real
crisis facing the nation yet he is
insisting that there is a need for
judicial overhaul bear in mind that he
is on trial facing corruption charges
now on Monday as the countries was in a
state of protests and paralysis because
of this Nationwide strike almost there
was a committee in the knesset it's
called the Constitution Law And Justice
committee it approved a bill that would
give the government more control over
the selection of Supreme Court Justices
so now as a protocol it moves through
the knesset for a second and third
hearing the government says there are no
plans to put it to a vote at least not
yet on April 2nd the knesset will take
about a month-long break for the
Passover an Independence Day holidays
and there is definitely talk of them
picking up the judicial overhaul after
that recess but the opposition is angry
they're saying that this signals to them
that the government is not serious about
negotiating or compromising the
president of Israel has invited both
parties to his home to negotiate and
discuss there are no plans yet for a
meeting of any kind and one thing that
remains unresolved in all of this and
unmentioned is the defense minister post
on Sunday evening this political crisis
escalated up to the level we saw
yesterday after Netanyahu
ousted yoav Galant the defense minister
Gallant was the first in the governing
coalition to suggest that the judicial
overhaul be paused because of concerns
about National Security there are many
in the military who oppose this judicial
reform reservists weren't showing up for
do Duty so we are hearing that as of yet
galat has yet to receive a formal
dismissal letter once that letter is
submitted the government by law has to
name a new defense minister within 48
Hours okay Natasha thank you for that
update Natasha go name live Thursday in
West Jerusalem well let's discuss this
further now with Nimrod goren who's a
senior fellow at the think tank Middle
East Institute is joining us live also
from West Jerusalem thank you very much
Mr Goran for being with us so what lies
ahead in your view can this delay on the
judicial overhaul lead to any compromise
between the government and those
opposing this plan
the delay first reflect the the enormous
power the report democracy brought this
movement in Israel had gathered over the
last four months citizens speaking up
managed to delay legislative forces of a
government that has a solid majority in
Parliament now the downside of that is
that as was mentioned in the report the
process is not stopped Netanyahu took a
time out but without his Coalition
pattern to continue from the same point
in time after the Connecticut zoomed its
operation in the weeks in nine months
time so basically speaking uh will sit
out there the people is in the air they
will resume the same process that we are
in over the last few weeks basically in
one month so you say Netanyahu took a
time out but do you think there is
really interest from him and his
Coalition Partners in reaching a
compromise on this plan
the specific law that was debated in the
last few days and the match of the
turmer was about is wanted his Coalition
part of that India himself are very much
committed to passing it's a vital thing
for Netanyahu in his path towards
getting out of his legal problem of the
case it is currently facing his Minister
of Justice is a personal commitment of
Faith or interest or faith to push that
flow so at the moment it seem quite
dedicated to continue with that and the
big question is whether those talks that
may be held within the premises of our
president will be sincere or will just
be playing for time because the
government still pushing the same agenda
whenever they have a timing a better
fits their ability to push it through
but how high a cost is this delay though
for Netanyahu vis-a-vis his Coalition
Partners the fractures within the
governing Coalition it seems are only
getting wider can can Netanyahu continue
leading this coalition government when
it appears that he's weakened now
yes he can and you can see what happened
yesterday because early morning
yesterday when they were the first
announcement about the possible delay in
the process and the News was that both
Minister Levin the Minister of Justice
and Minister Bengal of National Security
will resign we changed position within
the government none of them eventually
did so so people are not eager to live
their important positions and the
Coalition is still intact and when
Netanyahu is publicly committing himself
to actually delivering on that promise
to his Partners I think everybody is
giving the time and he's waiting because
there's no sense of urgency for them the
judges that are supposed to be in place
will be replaced only in the form so
there's nothing that should be happening
immediately on their side Beyond
managing to deliver and pass legislation
but practically speaking no problem for
netanyahua if it's being done in April
or in July okay now for now as you said
it doesn't look like the delay is taking
out the steam out of the protest
movement but will it in the long and if
Netanyahu as you say is paying for time
I mean one side is going to have to give
isn't it
we'll see which side it is because what
will happen now with some friction
within the protest moving between those
who are more open to engagement and to
see compromise to those who do not
believe in Antonio is sincere and do not
want to speak altogether until the
process is not stopped not delayed but
stopped so that's what we'll say let's
say in the coming months or so Israel is
entering a holiday season so generally
speaking it's likely that the protest
mood will lose a bit of momentum during
the weeks to come but when the knesset
resumes in late April and if no
compromise has been reached by then I
think the enormous power that was on
display over the last 48 hours but also
last three months you have to culminated
in general strike and universities being
closed those very same energies will be
back in play and I think Netanyahu will
face the same Stone powers that
prevented him for passing the
legislation this time when it tries to
do it again next time thank you so much
for talking to us thank you for your
Insight Nimrod Nimrod goren from the
Middle East Institute joining us there
from West Jerusalem